hello welcome to the debate on Sky News
I'm Martin Stanford here's our take on
developments brought together from
America the UK and around the world the
democratic debate but which presidential
candidate was not allowed to take part
here's a clue i'm here to announce my
candidacy for the president also today
the horrors of war abduction rape
slavery and massacre what are we doing
to save the victims of Isis there have
been calls for unity on both sides of
the political divide but with a
difference Paul Ryan has told his
Republican colleagues of course he'll be
Speaker of the House but only if
everyone supports him then the story of
the man who wants to run for the top job
but his party is apparently not as
enthusiastic as he is Professor Lawrence
Lessig claims to have been marginalized
by the Democrats will hear from him in
just a moment but as usual the Democrat
commentator Geoffrey Robinson is in New
York and the conservative commentator
Armstrong Williams is standing by in
Washington campaign finance reform
Jeffrey that seems a noble cause
absolutely it's a great cause along with
motherhood apple pie in the American
flag but what you're essentially doing
if you turn to Congress to come up with
a campaign reform is that you're asking
the poachers to redesign the henhouse so
there'll be no poaching good luck with
that Armstrong shouldn't they sort out
the way the money comes from you know
III think it's a very important topic
because people think believe that if
you're wealthy and your corporations you
hold too much sway over the political
process and that everyday Americans
voices don't really count the wealthy
donors and corporations will tell you
that is on a way to exercise your vote
and free speech uh but I do believe that
if you want to think about it on a much
deeper level if you look at what's
happening in the current presidential
race and you look at outsiders like a
colleague of Fiorina and a doctor ben
Carson and where you have someone like a
bush the establishment candidate who has
tons of money but it's not making a
difference and all dr. Carson's money is
raised through 56 and $150 donors and he
is over 700,000 like Bernie Sanders and
how well he's doing I think this is one
election that indicates that maybe
campaign finance performing and wealthy
donors and wealthy people don't have as
much sway over the political process as
we once gave them that credit having
well let's speak to the man
who wants to be President that's
Professor Lawrence Lessig who can join
us is it true professor that you just
fighting this campaign on this one issue
of where the money comes from and where
it goes well it's actually a little bit
more fundamental than just that one
issue and the basic fact about America
democracy is that we've allowed the
representative democracy to be corrupted
corrupted in part by the way we fund
campaigns but not just that the way
political gerrymandering makes our house
of representative this crazy polarized
institution both of these realities are
a product of the failure of our
government to maintain commitment to
this basic idea of a representative
democracy and what that means is our
Congress can't achieve any of the things
that the Democratic candidates are
talking about wanting them to do so it's
the unfortunate embarrassing
inconvenient truth about American
government that we have to have an
institution called Congress that can
actually work with the president to
achieve something and and unfortunately
we have to go to that institution to fix
itself that's just the reality of our
constitutional design but I think we
need to confront the problem of the
institution of Congress directly and try
to do something about it and that's what
this campaign is really about but what
would you do I mean it's an imperfect
system probably most Americans would
agree with that but it's the best one on
offer they might say too well of course
it's not the best one on offer and what
we could do is pass statutory reform
that would radically change the
influence both of money and these
polarized politics inside the system I
mean what are the problems i think that
defines this debate about money is that
so many people have spoken about it as
if the only solution is a constitutional
amendment which of course many people
think is just impossible but that's just
not true we could change the way
campaigns are funded tomorrow through a
statute in the united states congress
and we could change the way Congress
itself is selected tomorrow through a
statute in the united states congress
and so what we need to do is to build
the movement that says to
Congress we demand you fix yourself and
I think that a presidential campaign is
the only political Avenue in the
American political system for building
that movement and so my candidacy is
about saying to the Democrats look we
have to acknowledge the dead elephant in
the middle of the room which is Congress
and unless we find a way to fix that and
to build a political movement to fix
that then this is just fantasy politics
you know it's entertaining and it's a
it's a kid's enlivening and it gives us
hope but when we wake up the next
morning we realize you know none of the
things that they're talking about a
possible until we actually find a way to
fix it let me bring in Jeffrey and
Armstrong at this point Jeffrey it seems
a noble intent but look even if a
president campaigned on the issue and
got public support on the issue
presidents don't get their own way in
your system do they well the idea i mean
the the very first job of all
politicians is to get reelected that's
what they all do whether it be in
Congress or Parliament in Britain or
anywhere you must get reelected that's
your premier your first job and you get
elected with all of the chicane arree
that the professor is against and i am
too i mean i agree totally with them
although i do question his idea of
changing how congress is elected by
statute that's it that's in the
Constitution you would need a
constitutional amendment to do that and
because it's part of the original
articles it'll just never happen however
you can have a electoral reform but it
would take an overwhelming majority of
Democrats in the House and the Senate
and a Democratic president to force it
down the throats of the Republicans who
don't want it because they're benefiting
from it you also have this problem of
gerrymandering which I suspect the
Democrats if they had their druthers
would simply redistricting tire country
in favor of the Democrats is what they
do because again the first job of the
politician is to get reelected that's
one of the ways they do it I'm strongest
Jeffrey Wright that there is no
agreement across any aisle between the
two major parties about the need for any
change here well you know I actually
think that Professor blessing
and I may have some common ground here I
was um really taken back by his
eloquence and what he said you know I'm
always nitpicking to find an area where
I disagree but interesting enough I
don't disagree with him on anything and
I think what he's saying is much deeper
which Jeffrey is not saying is that both
political parties have become corrupt
they protect the establishment we put
forward these establishment candidates
like the Clintons and the bushes and
others and we make Americans the world
to believe that they're the best and the
brightest that America has to offer to
lead our great nation and this is not
true a part of our political process
especially when the finalists have this
in mind they made it clear that every
two years a housewife a professor a
farmer would come to Washington make
sure that that it would not become so
stalemate so stagnant that you keep
fresh ideas and keep the interesting
interests of the American people at hand
they never ever envisioned a permanent
political class that continue to stay in
office supported by the media supported
by special interest groups and where the
two-party system come together to keep
others out and I do think in order for
our democracy to thrive and reach its
true potential we need people like
professor Lessig challenging the system
and somehow nothing he has to work
outside of the system where he gets the
right kind of notoriety by the media
where it sort of catapults him to a
position where the media forces him to
get his numbers up where he does take
that stage on the on the debate stage to
express his ideas because I think many
people resonate with his kind of ideas
that we've become to lot with two
political parties and it's very
destructive for us in the long term you
know professor maybe you're taking
sucker and encouragement from the Labor
Party here in the UK who had a candidate
who had a couple of ideas and many of
the commentariat said he had no hope in
hell he's leader of the party now albeit
in opposition but tell me you you want
this citizen Equality Act that if you
get your way you'd you'd bring into
force in 2017 just give us some
headlines from that what would that act
do well yeah thank you and I and I
completely agree that the way to
recognize this fight is to understand it
as the off the opera
tunity for an outsider to force really
both of these parties to change
themselves on its first of all just not
true that you have to amend the
Constitution to change the way Congress
selects itself article 1 section 4 gives
Congress the power to change its mode of
election and it's done it many times
over history and so the citizen Equality
Act would set up a procedure that was
outlined by a nonpartisan group fair
vote that would make it possible for
there to actually be representative
House of Representatives not this
polarized institution we have right now
through multi-member districts and
ranked choice voting that would create a
representative house and it would change
the way campaigns are funded by giving
vouchers and matching funds to small
dollar contributors so that we don't
depend so much on the large contributors
to fund campaigns this would radically
change the way Congress functions now of
course Congress is going to resist it
the inside is going to resist it that's
exactly why I'm finding it so hard to
get on stage but I think the American
people are just like the British people
with the Labor Party upset that we just
saw I think the American people are
incredibly anxious and frustrated with
the existing system and they would step
up if we gave them a chance you look
skeptical Jeffrey as you often do yeah
yeah well first of all I mean Armstrong
never listens to what I say just against
it because I say it he talks about the
the political classes that he doesn't
want to see running for office but don't
forget the Constitution was written by a
political class permanent political
class Jefferson and Adams and and and
Washington and that whole bunch where
the elite in in America that time and
then the professor says that Congress
has changed many times the way it is
elected a name three professor yeah well
okay first Congress was constituted
through multi-member districts then a
statute change that and we didn't have
multi-member districts and then in 1967
let me finish 1967 Congress established
the winner-take-all system that we have
right now look I'm a professor of
constitutional law this is one thing I
know pretty well Congress has the power
I professor of the copyright law
no I'm a professor of constitutional law
which I have taught ever since 1991
Congress has the power itv1 Congress has
not changed the way it selected it is
still elected by districts in the states
to form a kind of parliamentary system
inside the house of representatives okay
do you want to put a thousand dollars on
this no he doesn't because you mean you
may need thousand bucks to run for
president and by the way you're running
for the Presidency not president
Armstrong let me just get you to
interject here what the professor seems
to be suggesting is you might get a
richer diversity of opinion represented
in Congress now heaven forfend you guys
might have to start doing coalition
deals between various smaller parties
wouldn't that be something that would
invigorate American political life
absolutely listen I'm not agreeing with
the professor because he may be a
Democrat us might have a run as an
independent I agree with him because
it's the only thing that's going to
sustain us as a real democracy for
generations to come if you look at
what's happening out in our own process
on the GOP side they're doing everything
they can undermine Donald Trump and
eventually dr. ben Carson full
disclosure on business management
because they are not a part of the
establishment they see them as bringing
wreckage and have it wrecking havoc on
the system and their loss they don't
know what to do they're just hoping that
these voters will come to their senses
and restore order so that establishment
can take the rightful place but guess
what guys it's not happening so what the
percept professors say we're seeing
happening right now in America would've
voted just outraged they don't want this
step respect but it won't ID they don't
want anyone with an establishment resume
with an elective resume it's time to
give Outsiders that's why I voice like
professor Lessig it's important because
he may not be the one to conquer it but
he starts the tiny drip the drip drip
drip that pays the way they're really
changed this lockdown that both
political parties have consumed on our
political process for way too long and
we pay the price if we lose in the long
run professor let me ask the point here
that sometimes people who look at this
system say that a system such as yours
might allow hey the system as it is
might allow somebody who's politically
naive or inexperienced
to get into the White House but your
system might let more likely now that
would make America a weaker place
wouldn't it don't you have to serve your
time in some instrument of government as
a governor as a senator before you take
on the biggest job in the land well I
think ordinary times that's exactly
right but I think the problem is when
the system itself becomes the problem
when the institution itself becomes
corrupted it only can be changed by
someone on the outside the framers of
our Constitution envisioned that when
they created the opportunity to call for
a convention to propose amendments to
the Constitution that was envisioned to
be a way for people outside of Congress
to try to rise up and to challenge a
corrupted Congress and that's the same
things going on here I I think many
people in America look at this
institution and believe it's deeply
corrupted but the fact that not a single
person on the democratic debate stage
even talked about the institution of
Congress even mention the idea of
publicly funding elections even
recognizing as Armstrong is is
highlighting that there's a perfectly
obvious way that Congress could be fixed
and fix itself I'm is evidence that we
need someone from the outside to bring
this forward and and that's and that's
the primary job that I'm trying to serve
Professor Lawrence Lessig thanks for
being with us today thank you now a
reminder you can catch up with the Sky
News debate on apple TV on roku and on
ketchup and of course you can find us at
Sky News calm / us sometimes the horrors
of war are difficult to comprehend we
see the pictures and hear the stories
the and akele is an iraqi member of
parliament Vianne i want to share a
moment from earlier this year when you
demanded passionately to Parliament that
more must be done to stop the abduction
rape slavery homelessness and massacre
of your people in northern Iraq by
Islamic state here's the class
no the bus that's the outline my mama
say Burmese man come see me at sharp
what I dunya TV Vienna's joining us from
northern Iraq on a connection which we
hope is going to work well for us today
VN thank you for joining us here in
London tell me since you made that
appeal has the situation for the Yazidi
people got any better thank you for you
unfortunately the switch situation for
their GDP fall it's it's very bad after
14 months ago when the item attacked
their villages since now the situation
it's same since now we have four hundred
twenty thousand people are refugees in
that living in that can see the
kurdistan region and we have about 3,000
years auntie SED woman are captured by
Isis until now and those people in
becomes they living in very very bad
situation especially in the winter now
the weather it's a very fall and we
don't have anything we don't have
schools we don't have health center we
don't have enough food we don't have
enough water and really the situation of
those refugees aren't very glad you made
a personal appeal dint you to the
President of the United States and
indeed to his wife to help what happened
after that nothing happens yes nothing
happened i would say I i sent that
letter for that a media michelle obama
before seven months ago and tell her to
help us to have those girls are
kidnapped by ISIL but nothing happens
she don't answer me let me bring in
Jeffrey and Armstrong at this time
Armstrong the United States gets Appeals
for help from all sorts of people in all
sorts of predicaments but the ants
situation seems particularly severe why
no help do you think or you know let me
just congratulate her on her courage for
risking it all to be a part of our
broadcast today and she's only repeating
the narrative that we've heard from so
many inside about the rate and the
divisiveness and how people use money to
woo people to read brings about
divisions among families and talk about
how people are kidnap and our children
are treated like animals and I'm
subjugated you know listen there are
millions of crisis is that would love to
get the attention of the first lady in
our president of the United States and
just because we hear the horrors through
her emotions as she tell her story
doesn't mean that her Horrors in that
narrative have reached the doorsteps of
the house and they're probably just
unaware it's not the necessary channel
if you're really looking for real help
and real solutions to your issues is
going directly to the White House
there's so many other channels that you
have right where you are their
diplomatic channels there's the UM
President of the United States listen I
mean the fact that you've not heard
anything from the White House is not an
indication that they just don't care
it's just that so many people are
bombarding them constantly in their
staffs with issues very similar to this
but it does not minimize on them in any
way the horror that continues to exist
in a place i like iraq and I'm just
curious you know I know Jeffrey has to
get his um and put in on this but I'm
just wondering what she would feel that
we could do to be helpful to her
especially for people like us in the
media we have platforms where we can
make a difference to give rise to voices
like her because obviously what she
needs is more attention to the situation
she finds herself in so more people who
right near where she is can sort of give
some outpouring of support to help sort
of minimize the circumstances that she
faces Jeffrey welcome to Vienna
by Jeffrey it is a complex situation
over there and the Americans are doing
what they would say are some things to
try and tackle Isis but in the Yazidi
case it's not enough is it well listen I
want to stand shoulder to shoulder with
my friend Armstrong on this one he's
absolutely right young you you are
fighting the right fight and and the
world is standing with you the fact that
you haven't heard from Michelle Obama
says to me as it does to Armstrong she
never got the letter because she's the
kind of person who would respond if she
knew so writer again right right every
member of Congress right every member of
the Senate right to the UN keep the
campaign a lot because as I say you are
fighting the right fight it's a very
difficult thing for any government to
come up with the right solution because
this may be one of those problems where
there is no right solution but you're on
the side of right and of God these days
unfortunately it takes god and the side
of right a little bit longer than it
used to to make things right I'm viernes
Armstrong suggested if there is a
shopping list if there's one or two
things you would like done right now
what are they the very important things
now I am looking for anyone to help
those girls escape them from I supporter
and we need anyone to help especially
the International Organization for
sending them any force ended the human
tarian things for those refugees people
and we need someone to help because we
have and many girls are they can't
escape from ISIL but the situation for
those girls or for those women our
children are very very terrible
especially psychological a situation of
them but we don't have any sensor health
or we don't have any Center to have
those escaped girls to to give him a gig
or rehabilitation care to to help their
fault that because well because that we
need many many things for from
international countries but
I i would like to cite to say something
I know that problem in the world are
very big but the cave they'd indicates a
case it is very different it is the
first time one of community small
community living in Iraq that I so when
can kill all the man and ski I'm a
kidnapped all the women and children I
can't them rape them at you think this
is a new skin new case this is not
something like a war orphan some problem
I know that there they are very problem
in the world of this case it's a very
special case especially we don't have
any longer and strong Lobby in the West
or in the any place of the world to help
us what about your other MPs in the
Iraqi parliament as such do you not have
any sympathy from them to see if they
can use their influence to help the
women and children you talk about
unfortunately at the situation in the
Iraq in general it's a very terrible I
know some of them or most of those and a
member of the Iraqi parliament light
will help me but we don't we can do
anything because the situation for Eric
it's a very bad something there are some
problem from Salina from gr from
Christian all of them are in problem I
think it can't help me now who can help
me the international countries not help
me I I mean help my community and
Jeffrey this is as you indicated a tough
nut to crack isn't it because there are
so many players now we know the Russian
involvement in Syria is causing concern
we know the French are over there we
know the Turks are getting worried about
what Isis are doing to say it's a mess
is an understatement it is a mess and
and well of you and I'm sorry and I
can't shift the river we may be able to
move a few drops of water in the other
section so let me volunteer this and I'm
sure I'm strong will join me and I hope
you will too if Vaughn will will send us
enough information in English we will
use our social media research resources
to try and get this word out this
program will go out on social media we
will do what we can even sending tweets
and and facebook messages directly to
the White House and various members of
Congress and the United Nations to see
if we can't move this thing forward I
know I'm strong I'll join us like I
certainly hope sky will too fan it must
be very difficult for hope for optimism
of any kind to survive in the
predicament of the Yazidi people right
now but as you face another winter how
do you think the spirit of the people is
right now almost there people are close
the the hope for the future three
because anyone any family if you give
any easy family and to ask them about
the future they don't know everything
it's dark for us because I tell you know
schools for the children and all most of
those families now in the camps they
lost one of that her family or their
family lost them and some of them are
killed and some of them are kidnapped
and they don't have any income any
school no school no anything no future
real we are all things now it's a dark
for the Ethical People v n thank you
very much Jeffrey and Armstrong thank
you both for your conversation today as
well and that's it for this edition of
the debate you can continue watching sky
news on apple TV on roku and catch up
and of course on Sky News calm until
next time goodbye
you